jean morin vient de voir son fromage la
religieuse sacré le meilleur au québec
véritable fierté pour le fromager
centricois une grande récompense
d'abord pour toute équipe on a famille
qui produisent le lait bien entendu que
ces retombées pour l'ensemble l'ensemble
la ruralité
mais pour assurer la pérennité des
fromageries comme la sienne le prochain
gouvernement à ottawa devra protéger
davantage les artisans comme lui c'est
les récents accords commerciaux avec les
états unis et l'europe par exemple le
sont de bien mauvais augure selon lui
malgré les compensations promises par le
gouvernement sortant
on s'ouvre à ma gueule que les prochains
le prochain gouvernement soit capable de
mettre ses culottes d'accepter que le
canada que producteur de fromage mecs là
rogers de freinage qui se classe au
niveau international et concèze de
prendre le canada comme une terre
d'accueil devraient tous les fromages
d'internet
le message du fromager est tout à fait
légitime dit ces candidats néo
démocrates et bloquistes du centre du
québec
ils promettent de se porter à la défense
de cette industrie s'ils sont élus les
conservateurs en 2015 je me rappelle
très bien on leur disait arrêtée par des
branches dans gestion de l'offre et dont
on fait pas de brèche
et puis après ça les libéraux ont
contenu la même chose 8 points 4 % en
quatre ans de brèches dans la gestion de
l'offre
alors on peut plus continuer comme ça il
faut absolument agir et nous ce qu'on a
dit le npd c'est fini les brèches dans
la gestion de l'offre
le bloc s'engage à déposer un projet de
loi dès les débuts de la première
session parlementaire un projet de loi
qui va exiger que le gouvernement
s'engage à ne pas utiliser à nouveau la
gestion de l'offre comme monnaie de
change en quelque accord international
que ce choix est ce on y tient mordicus
au même titre que les compensations qui
ont été promises de la musique aux
oreilles de jean marc est d'avis que le
prochain gouvernement fédéral doit aussi
aider les fromagers d'ici à rayonner
davantage sur la scène internationale
quant à 0
ou pas du takkal mondiaux que nous
sommes aussi de graver votre voix de
bons fromages et surtout les fromages de
classe mondiale jean maureille assure
qu'il suivra la campagne en cours tout
aussi sérieusement qu'il supervise la
fabrication de ses fromages
ici jean françois dumas radio-canada
sainte élizabeth de warwick